hi everyone it's jerry
let's have a look at a game from round
six
of the alt box norway chess tournament
2020
on the white end ariana tari and he's
paired against ali reza ferrugia
so let's hop right in atari opening with
e4
farouza replying with the caro khan
defense
we have an exchange carro
and when you're playing this defense
what is one of your main objectives if
not
the main objective it is to deploy
your light square bishop outside your
pawn chain
so white reacts and now hits black where
they're a bit weak
that's defended and h3 follows
something to quickly note sometimes
there can be moves like this
to pull the queen away from its defense
of b7
with the idea to next take the knight
pawn and then the brook
it's not working here because
that's mate anyhow
sometimes this can be an idea in this
game it's h3 an early commitment
with the king side pawn flight square
for the king
more short term this guy on g4 has to do
something so
quick pop quiz where should the bishop
where should the bishop go
h5 or d7 feel free to pause the video
okay in the game bishop d7 this was the
first moment
that grabbed my attention when i skimmed
through this game
i thought to myself bishop h5
if this was let's say a bullet game
this would be my knee-jerk reaction the
issue with bishop h5
is that white can go hunting for a pawn
g4 trade bishops
and give this knight a boot from its
defense of d5
white wins upon it's not the end of the
day
black can react energetically in the
center breaking with e5
white only has one piece out and has
made several kingside concessions
but still a pawn is upon
okay in this game it's bishop d7 some
natural moves coming in
and after this ninth move e6 i feel like
white
can be a bit happy
happy that black has not achieved
this objective to deploy the light
square bishop outside of the pawn chain
it's inside continuing rook on a half
open file
battery is formed
and e7 is left vacant for a knight
this can often be a nice pivot towards
the king side
maybe f5 or g6
i think this next move by white
looks to try and take advantage of this
decision to put the bishop on d6 rather
than
e7 with the bishop on
e7 black would have
no concerns whatsoever about this
possibility to take the knight
because black would be able to recapture
with the piece and
keep the structure as is so
what does black play
at this moment how to deal with this
possibility
black castles has no worries
about a damaged kingside structure why
is that
in general not a good idea to have your
king side damaged and the queen still be
on board
but there isn't a way to take advantage
of these
weaknesses that would be created after
this move
in the game knight d2 is played
if white goes forward with this f6 h6
h5 are all weakened but how do you make
use of those squares you don't
soon it'll be black who goes on the
offensive throwing the king in the
corner
stacking the rooks on the g file good
luck to white weathering that storm
a move such as queen c2 is not really a
threat at all
the king could go in the corner this
pawn would be poison
white will now lose a piece
okay no bishop takes knight both sides
now connecting the rooks
knight h5 this was the first think by
farouja
about five minutes spent on knight to h5
a black knight on the f4 square
is a real beast
two checks in mind has some nice
pressure on the kingside pawns
tough to work around tough to control
f4 with the pawn
now that h3 is in if g3 is played
white would just be asking for some
sacrifice with the queen and bishop
as well as the knight keying in on that
square
so you just have to work around a knight
on f4
queen d1 hinting at maybe a knight move
generating a threat on h5 f6 follows
it's committal the diagonal is a bit
more weakened towards the king
e6 is sensitive but i believe at the end
of the day the positives are outweighing
the negatives
what are these positives well first of
all let's get a couple more moves in
bishop e3 knight f4
and bishop to f1 what do i see
what sticks out to me most about this
position
it is the quality of the knights the
black knights stand very well
both are in the key 16 squares of the
board
the white knights this guy is out of
bounds
the knight on d2 is under control by the
pawn on d5
and even though the white knight on f3
is inside
this key area it is under control by
that f6
move this is the main positive i'm
seeing behind
this advance i guess we can say the c3
pawn does a good job of controlling the
knight on c6
but the knight on c6 has at least
a useful role in supporting
if black wants to play this that knight
supports a central
break e5
this is the biggest factor i see about
this position the quality
of the knights i believe the black
knights far outweigh
the white knights black has nice control
over this position
and i believe it's black's control over
this position that gives him the
confidence to make this
next move this highly committal move g5
many weaknesses are created now on the
king side black has a clear
idea in mind with this move
it's very cave manish black's ready to
throw the king in the corner
put the rook on g8 and then break with
g4
and go after the king a very clear
idea but it is not so clear how you
defend
against it white
has a tall task ahead of him
okay this night first of all
if you try to get rid of them with g3
well white isn't even threatening to win
material with g3 so if you're going to
make committal moves such as g3 you
ought to be generating a threat
you ought to really be threatening to
win some material
white wouldn't be threatening to win
material let's just say king here if you
take the knight
where's that bishop going nowhere
black gets the material right back and
whoa
rook g8 is hitting really fast
with check okay so node g3
we have a thematic reply c4
you play in the flanks your king is now
weakened okay let's break it open in the
center let's open a diagonal or two
let's maybe get some tempo against your
queen here here i go
c4 it is king h8 rook c1 rook g8
nearby g4 this knight
white deems it as intolerable at this
stage so
some concession removing this knight on
f4 bishop takes knight
an imbalance is on board now how
exactly should black recapture i'll
throw this one to you as a pop quiz
bishop takes bishop
or pawn takes bishop feel free to pause
the video
okay in the game bishop takes bishop
it may be tempting to want to
immediately peel open this
file for this rook or really both rooks
but
these guys would be shut out of the game
with this pawn fixed
basically on f4 there's no guarantee
that this knight moves so
it's basically a fixed pawn
black wants it all and what i mean by
that is he wants to keep this diagonal
opened
and still crack open the g file it's
just a moment away
g4 and the g file will open so this is
the unopposed bishop
has very nice influence over the board
pinning the knight
its eyes are open the queen's eyes are
opened
continuing we have b4 so this was one of
the ideas behind
this capture on f4 at this stage it was
to
pull away the bishop from seeing b4
something to maybe note at this stage is
that
you know this a3 move is the top one of
the top moves by the engine
but this is anything but human
uh i would be really surprised to see
a human go with the a3 move at this
stage
it's idea to support b4 it just comes
off as far too
slow you know the king side is soon to
be on fire
and it almost feels like you're passing
you're making a nothing move with a3 so
in capturing this knight at least going
for some forceful variation
this is far more human-like um to take
on f4 going for a forcing line
and then following up with b4 which is
actually generating a serious threat
the threat here to take on d5 and then
take advantage of what would be
a pinned knight so black gets
out of any pin with queen d6
the knight is kicked away the pressure
on d4 is now released
some c5 follows one of the suggestions
is some kind of rook lift
with the intention to lend some lateral
defense
on the third rank g3 is a
is soon to be a sensitive point okay but
in this game it is c5 so there is a
majority that's been created
but this is hitting really really fast
queen c7 g3
what is the reaction by black
how would you play at this stage feel
free to pause the video
okay here we go a big moment in the game
the bishop's attacked it doesn't budge
in fact it doesn't budge for several
moves
be captured for several moves doesn't
budge for several moves
the reaction here is g4 the break is in
there
all of these prep moves have been played
g5 king in the corner rook g8 you have
to justify
all those moves you have to get the
break in
it's in no time to take the bishop
because the knight falls with check and
queen takes f4 good luck
no luck can help light here
alright so no pawn takes bishop instead
pawn takes pawn
rook takes bishop h3
the rook falls back not just to any
square keeps g8 vacant
for the other rook simply can't take now
it's a pin so white is out of the pin
and also stays off of h2
he'd really be asking for trouble here
there'd be a sacrifice on g3
e5 as the follow-up hitting an
unprotected bishop
and they're traded no time to take the
bishop here because it would be a
checkmate
in two
so what's played is knight to h2
where's this guy go nowhere
queen h3 no time
to take the bishop yet again because of
mate on g2
rook g1 the rooks are now stacked
can you take the bishop now no
still no good queen e2 is played if you
take the bishop
there would follow rook g2 this is a
problem
and what do you do here if knight to f3
there can follow e4 kicking the knight
away from defense
of h2 white's position collapses
so the bishop remains poison
queen e2 e4 now there is simply no
knight f3
same story if this rook to g2
rook to g2 if the knight goes to f1 to
defend
that's me the rooks are disconnected
okay so after e4 what do we have
rook to c3 adding some support over
g3 but now
uh after knight to f5 both nights
first the one on f4 created a
serious concession in white's camp
white parted ways with their dark square
bishop and now this one
is entering the scene with devastating
effect
hitting d4 and looking to crash
through on g3
maximal pressure on g3 all pieces
pointing at the g3 pawn
white at this stage lashes out um
captures on e4 there is no good solution
unfortunately for white here
after the recapture we have queen takes
e4
and it should be no surprise
an accident is going to happen in this
intersection
g3 intersection square bishop takes
first
if you take this bishop the knight
pounces
in the game rook g2 so if pawn takes
there would follow knight takes g3
check you have to take now
and white erickson black crashes right
through
how do you stop queen g2 or g1
for mate next you don't really you have
to
give away even more material and this is
of course
toast for white
so what is played as rook g2 the back
rank is now a bit weakened
the rooks have taken some steps up so
black transfers his attention
to the e-file rook e7 has the support of
the knight
queen defends the back rank black
insists
and white resigns there's no good
solution
to rookie one
leading to the win of more material or
some
type of checkmate sequence so i'll show
one variation one or two variations if
let's say
rook to c1 there can follow
bishop takes knight yeah i'll just go
with this one variation bishop takes
knight rook takes
queen f3 check king g1
some rook to the g file king f1
and that's mate so this is simply too
much
to weather for white and he threw in the
towel
so a very nice game
uh farouja playing the caro khan
and winning in 34 moves
with this early launching of the g
pawn only at a moment though where he
had very nice control
in the center uh something i'd like to
point out
is in this early stage i think an
improvement
will be right around here to
an improvement would be to not deploy
the bishop but rather say
my queen did her job this a3
you know mission accomplished with
ensuring the bishop is still inside the
pawn chain
a better idea would be queen d2 and
queen to e2 strengthening control over
e5
looking to pivot there with the knight
and put the other one on f3
anyhow i i share all that uh
with the assistance of my good friend
stockfish 12.
but this would be a an improvement
is what i'm getting at instead of the
bishop g5 which turned out to really
backfire some nice tempe
we're gained about uh we're gained
against the bishop on g5
okay once more after rook here white
resigned
let's have one look here at the
tail of the tape
here we go we could see how it plays out
so right here after bishop to d6 that's
where there was a big drop with
bishop g5 uh it does go back
up a little bit for white but you have
to really be
completely like super accurate with your
defensive moves really tough to find
this was right around the point i was
saying that a3
was considered best instead of taking
the knight but
yeah no who no human is really going to
play a3 there i don't think
and it just goes downhill at the end of
the day where do we stand
average senti pawn loss for uh
aryantari 49 to farouja's
18. uh i didn't share this with you yet
but these were the
show a couple pictures at the end here
this is right around the point where g4
g5 was on board
a couple pictures of these guys in
action
both of them very concentrated um
yeah so a very tight game
a very tense game i should say and a
nice
nice idea implemented by farouja
in this one 34 move win with the carol
khan
anyhow as usual feel free to leave any
feedback
to this video in the comments section
below
i hope you enjoyed it and maybe took a
thing or two away
that's all for now take care bye
you